and the Oscar goes to Trent Reznor and  Atticus  [Applause]  [Music]  this is the first Academy Award a  nomination for Trent Reznor and Atticus  Ross  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  Wow is this really happening  when we finished work on the social  network we were very proud of her work  and happy to just be involved in this  film and to be standing up here in this  company is humbling and flattering  beyond words I'd like to especially  thank the Academy for recognizing our  work here and David Fincher David  Fincher thank you so much for the  opportunity I also like to thank my  wonderful wife Mary Queen I love you so  much  times nearly out so go in for my  improvise a little David everyone who  bought the film to life thank you so  much  Trent I think you're a genius a great  friend and a genius wonderful light wife  Claudia and our three children lovely  thank you  [Music]